s'abonner
ce qui s'est passé
Quoi
nous faisons A c'est notre moyen de transport
En fait, les traîneaux sont nos ancêtres depuis des temps immémoriaux.
nos grands-parents allaient avec eux à l'hôpital.
Maintenant, ils sont allés dans les villages, les districts et les provinces.
Bien sûr, les gens sont curieux
ils s'entendent et nous les aidons
comme je l'ai dit nous sommes
s'abonner
IL
J'attends très très Bazar en dessous je
alors Dieu merci je suis content de l'invention
s'abonner
Oui, c'est pour garder notre culture vivante
Nous continuons
Notre ancienne tradition est l'équitation
courses de luge jeux de javelot
nous faisons tout ce que nous montrons
nous aidons nos clients ici
Sous quelles conditions
nous montrons que nous vivons
j'essaie de survivre